a turn of the crank a a spin of the
wheel fear dread excitement what is it
you feel the cycle resets we live once
more to repeat the mistakes we've made
before so again we join our yellow
friend remember my dears death is never
the end
hello Internet welcome to film Theory
the best theory Show online provided you
log in first I I don't know the password
too bad for you I guess for everyone who
does remember their password today we're
diving back into the Twisted world of
Don't Hug Me I'm Scared in case you need
a quick refresher don't hug me I'm
scared or dhmas started as a classic
YouTube horror series that mixed Tickle
Me Elmo with dead space it was
children's edutainment with a heavy dose
of existential dread but then earlier
this year dhmas did The Impossible it
got itself a full-blown real-life TV
show on the British Channel 4 and oh boy
is this thing full of cryptic secrets
and hidden mysteries for one this guy
right here the yellow guy he's probably
a dead kid because of course he's a dead
kid this is a theory Channel after all
we've got our standards in this case we
theorize that yellow guy is the puppet
representation of a child named David a
child who is tragically killed by his
mother Leslie during a car accident the
dollhouse and puppet world of dhms that
we now see is just Leslie trying to come
to grips with this traumatic event from
her past and move on but that's hardly
been the only Theory that's popped up
around this new series one major
unsolved mystery revolves around these
strange symbols that appear in various
locations all throughout the six episode
run I actually first noticed these back
during the fly teaser in Spring of 2022
as one of the symbols appeared on a
sticky note in the fridge at the time we
had nothing to go off of in our resident
chemistry expert staff was able to
confirm that it wasn't some sort of
chemical structure so we filed it away
as a weird little detail that might pop
up again and pop up again it did loyal
theorists these symbols are everywhere
on the show on computers on
refrigerators on blackboards and most
notably of all on the cover of the
mysterious book that Leslie gives yellow
guy in the final episode of the Season
you wanted this didn't you and while at
first these little drawings might seem
just like random shapes used to decorate
the scene in reality their symbols with
a deeper meaning that can absolutely be
solved and that's important because
these characters are clearly stuck in a
cycle and decoding the book might be
their only hope in Breaking that cycle
don't forget to change your batteries
loyal theorists cause it's Theory time
it's Theory time you'll see now well I'd
love to sit here in the recording closet
and tell you that today's episode is
going to be me solving the symbol
mystery I can't do that because someone
else beat me to the punch you see as I
was doing research for this episode I
stumbled across a series of videos
produced by the channel REM games here
on YouTube a series of videos where he
claimed do exactly what I was trying to
do solve the coded message on the front
of the book and after watching the
videos you know what I think he pretty
much nailed it me and the rest of Team
theorists love the way that he solved
the mystery so instead of just rehashing
it all ourselves only to come to the
same conclusions we decided to invite
him over today to represent his research
in the episode hey Ram hey I'm Remy yes
like the rat I'm a YouTube gamer and
theorist who tolerates FNAF and uses
glitchy text in my video titles welcome
to the family sir some tells me you're
gonna fit right in I also like the
internet Creepypasta stuff which is how
I got involved with the whole Don't Hug
Me mystery you see while I was watching
I noticed a few of the symbols showing
up over and over again obviously the
biggest and most important one is going
to be on the cover of the book that
Leslie gives to yellow guy but you'll
notice that inside that big symbol are a
bunch of smaller ones ones that we see
repeated in other parts of the world for
example this symbol here on the top
right can be seen on the spine of the
yellow book in the show's intro or the
symbol here which appears in both the
show's trailer as well as this spatial
distribution that yellow guy drafts up
in the final episode clearly they mean
something they're put in those places
with intent but how do you start to
figure out what they could possibly mean
well you look for instances where a
symbol is directly related to something
someone says and that's exactly what we
get in episode four try my name oh yeah
okay
that inverted P is duck's name this is
further supported by the fact that
during Duck's funeral in episode 2 we
see that same symbol on his plane again
the symbol and duck are connected
exactly you know where else it shows up
here on this title card from episode 3
family but you see what else is there
it's another one of these symbols the
one with a bunch of circles and curved
lines so knowing that the one symbol
represents duck what have we just seen
happen to him in the story well red guy
has joined him for dinner back at the
house that curvy symbol represents red
guy that's why it's their two names on
this title card and why yellow guy isn't
mentioned and again that's not the only
time that we see this symbol making
sense as red guy's name we see the
symbol appear again in the trash of red
guy's office during episode 1 jobs
clearly this is him throwing away
paperwork that's been addressed to him
there's also the sticky note that's on
the fridge that I mentioned earlier
which would make sense if he's marking
something on the fridge as his so lastly
we need yellow guy's name and while we
don't have as one-to-one evidence to
show this we can figure figure it out by
process of elimination when the show
shows a wide shot of Leslie's dollhouse
in episode 6 we can see three symbols
written on the walls the first is duck's
name we know that for sure the second is
red guy's name which we feel highly
confident in which means that the last
symbol here this little robot face with
a pointy tail by process of elimination
that must be yellow guy which now brings
us back to the mystery book within that
one huge symbol on the cover you can see
all three characters are represented but
why what are the creators trying to say
with this new language and what are
these other symbols connected to our
main three well if we look at the way
that the cover is constructed it can
actually tell us a lot this is going to
be a massive oversimplification of some
complicated Linguistics but there are a
lot of different ways to make a written
language for example English and other
romantic languages are made up from
alphabets they have letters that you can
put together to form syllables or words
and then you can use those to make up
more complicated ideas but that's not
the only way to make a written language
another major way is by using law
logograms where different symbols
represent individual words kanji in
Japanese and ancient Egyptian
hieroglyphics those are examples of
logographic writing systems but if you
take it one step further than logograms
you get ideograms which are symbols
meant to represent entire ideas so stuff
like numbers or the symbols that we use
in math those are ideograms and number
one represents the entire concept of one
just like the plus symbol represents the
entire concept of addition languages
made up from ideograms are able to tell
very complex stories with relatively few
symbols if you want an example we can
look at unlws or the anchor non-linear
writing system using this we can break
this big squiggly line into smaller
squiggly lines each with their own
individual meaning like me or eats but
put together this symbol means I eat a
large fish so given how the individual
symbols on the cover of Leslie's book
all flow into one another it would make
sense then that the dhmas language Works
in a similar way to unlws yup the
individual dual symbols each convey an
idea that can be put together to make a
much longer and more complicated story
this would also explain why it took red
guy so many keystrokes to type out
yellow guy's name in the computer
episode maybe it's my name try my name
Remember The Hyphen he has to combine a
bunch of symbols to create the idea of
yellow guy also it's you know just a
funny joke yeah that too I suppose
Sometimes some things are in there just
to be funny no never we take everything
way too seriously here there is no such
thing as a joke or an Easter egg in this
house no sir just a bunch of sloppy lore
don't you mean lore not bad why thank
you but what's it all mean sure we've
decoded the three major symbols we know
how the writing system works but what's
it all trying to say honestly I'm not
sure I think it relates to those windows
in Leslie's room I'm actually glad you
brought those up because they're one
thing that you kind of glossed over in
your videos and something that I haven't
seen anyone else fully addressed just to
fill everyone in when yellow guy first
enters Leslie's room he walks past a
series of three Windows each with an
item from one of the episodes on display
there's a square window with the shuttle
dollops from episode 3 family a diamond
window with the shovel from episode 2
death and a circular window with the
batteries from episode 6 electricity but
notice the line on those windows they're
colored green red and yellow which
obviously is going to line up with the
characters in the series duck red guy
and yellow guy but the items don't
really seem to line up with the colors
they're assigned to I mean sure the
batteries in the yellow window make
sense because in that final episode
yellow guy changes his batteries and
suddenly becomes smart but duck can't
open the bag of chuttle dollops in
episode 3 now let's crack into these
shoddy D's
I can't in the end it's red guy who
manages to open the bag I think things
might go a little differently this time
[Music]
and the same thing happens with the
shovel despite being in the red window
red guy's the only one to never interact
with the shovel at all in episode 2.
yellow guy uses it to dig up Duck and
duck ultimately uses it to kill his
doppelganger actually no four doesn't
work there's three of us so why would
these items be associated with
characters who failed to use them on the
show well I suspect it's a hint to the
greater story that's happening here the
same story that's being told by the book
you see don't hug me I'm scared as a
story all about characters stuck in a
loop not only does Leslie outright say
this at the end of episode five
term the journey always ends up back at
home other characters openly acknowledge
how repetitive their lives are all we do
is sit around and then some guy comes
and tells us about Banks or vegetables
the cycle really seems to be getting to
Red guys
[Applause]
[Music]
and of course there's the picture of
yellow guy walking up the stairs as he's
walking up the stairs this is clearly
not the first time he's done this
despite having no explicit memory or
knowledge of it in the past so if we're
in a cycle that repeats over and over
maybe there are parts of the story that
play out differently in different
repetitions of that cycle during this
iteration of the loop yellow guy ended
up with the batteries while duck used
the shovel to kill his doppelganger and
red guy open the shuttle dollops but
clearly things aren't quite right things
didn't turn out for the best and that's
because things didn't align with what
Leslie has up here in her room red guy
didn't end up using the shovel and duck
doesn't open the shuttle dollops himself
that would actually make sense we know
for a fact that things can change during
each Loop first of all we see recurring
characters and props from the YouTube
series appearing here on the TV show
things like the clock teacher the
notepad the computer teacher and even
the food guy they're all here but are
used in very different ways there's also
repeated references to Clay Hill the
town that was supposed to be the focus
of dhmis's original TV pilot it's here
crossed out on the Blackboard of the big
boys room as well as here during the
transportation episode what about just
just down here I'm sorry
it shows that the cycle has some level
of awareness of the past with small
changes in each run inside joke or lore
and then here just take a look at this
house from the beginning of episode 5
compared to this house from the
beginning of episode six notice anything
different for the house in the episode 6
intro there are additional bricks on the
corners all the curtains and windows are
different colors and there are fewer
trees around the house when compared
with episode 5. this would make sense
because this is a different house in a
different Loop remember Leslie has to
reset everything at the end of episode
five and this my friends is what I
suspect the book is for it's telling
yellow guy the correct series of events
that he and his friends need to do
explaining what duck needs to do with
the shuttle dollops what red guy needs
to do with the shovel what yellow guy
needs to do with the batteries it's
telling yellow guy and us the story that
needs to happen in order for everything
to move forward we even get hints of it
on the cover thanks to the pictures
embossed in the leather there's a lot of
stuff on here that we can recognize from
the first six episodes Ducks decapitated
head yellow guys dismembered hand the
shovel the batteries the coin but a lot
of it just doesn't quite fit right
notice the worms sorry notice the Eagles
around the coin and Battery that
character had nothing to do with either
of those stories there's also this weird
decapitated yellow guy head on here
something that again we didn't see in
the first six episodes why are all of
these markings on the book if they never
happen well maybe it's because they're
supposed to happen this book is
literally a script for the right series
of events to help break the loop to end
the Suffering The torment so everyone
can just move on speaking of scripts you
know one thing that never quite sat
right with me throughout these first six
episodes grolton and hoverus a random
points throughout the episodes the show
just takes a break from the action so
the characters can sit down and watch
clips from this in Universe Wallace and
grommet spin-off it is weird it is
random and the sequences can last for a
surprisingly long time I just realized
brother's visit isn't until next month
gralton is the dog
no Croton is the man Harvest is the dog
I reckon but you know that when a
Creator chooses to include something so
prominently in their series you gotta
ask yourself why so I did have you
noticed who worked on these episodes
Leslie in episode 3 we can actually see
that she's credited as a script editor
for Golden and havrus and that's
interesting because it means that in
dhmas Leslie holds a position of
creative power so if she's a script
editor and also happens to be handing
yellow guy a book that explains
everything it's likely the book is a
script for the correct sequence of
events the only question left is why
what's it all for well it might be due
to forces beyond their control you see
during one of my re-watches I noticed
this offhand joke in episode 2 as lamp
explains what he thinks happens in the
afterlife well something tells me that
when we die we go into the center of the
earth and we must relive our lives but
as a performance for a new super race
known as the council and every time you
get it right you get a pound when I
first watched the show that always
struck me as a bit weird and
off-the-wall joke that was just so
strange that it didn't make any sense
but then I realized that this is how
episode 1 ends oh yes I almost forgot
you've earned this
[Music]
Doc is given the dhmis equivalent of a
one pound coin while everyone else is
left penniless now this could be Duck's
digital currency based around respect
but if we take what the lamp said at
face value this must mean that they
weren't being paid by the council for
their parts in reenacting this part of
their lives we've theorized in the past
that red guy has a creative soul but in
his jobs episode he winds up as a
manager of the factory knowing what we
know about him he would never be a
manager at a factory like that he didn't
do it right same thing with yellow guy
as the episode goes yellow guy grows old
in the factory and ultimately retires to
be with his family but if yellow guy is
really David then he wouldn't have lived
nearly as long as we see him live during
the storyline it appears that whatever
happened in this episode with duck was a
part of the correct order of events
needed for the series to progress which
also means the council or the people
deciding it all but then who or what is
the council well at first I thought that
maybe the council represented the cast
and crew of the series The creatives
Working to make the show a reality after
all the show breaks the fourth wall
constantly with performers producers and
directors visible to us as the audience
like here during episode 4 where we can
see several puppeteers red guy's actor
even co-creator Becky Sloan during the
episode itself or here in episode 6
where yellow guy sees two of the
puppeteers piloting the teachers in the
big boy room but then I remember that
there's a level in the house above
Leslie's room accessible via a stairwell
hidden in the back corner and so if
Leslie is a creator of sorts and what's
above creators in a creative industry
well that's the people with the money
producers who won't proceed with scripts
and fundam until you get it right heck
you could even argue that there may even
be a level above them the audience who
seem to be more than willing to watch
the same stories over and over and over
again with just slight variations but
also an audience who immediately blows
up and gets angry when something is just
slightly off it's funny Don't Hug Me I'm
Scared YouTube series spent so much of
its hidden Mystery talking about
creatives and how money corrupted what
should be a pure form of art with kids
entertainment I was actually surprised
that the TV show seemed to Veer so far
away from that sort of meta commentary
since it seems so important into the
creators in that original series I
suppose we just needed to look a little
bit harder didn't we is this is this
when we get to say the thing Yep this is
when we say the thing but hey that's
just a theory a film Theory and cuts and
a huge huge thank you to REM games for
joining us on this episode and sharing
his incredible research with us please
do me a favor go over to his Channel
right now it's linked on screen and
watch his six part series covering dhmas
he goes into so much more detail about
stuff we didn't have the chance to cover
today let me tell you he is digging even
further into the mysteries of the series
and other Series so go give him a watch
and then do me a favor comment on his
latest video something funny make sure
your comment includes the words
fluffernutter cause I just think that's
a really funny troll word thank you so
much for having me on it's been an honor
being here I'd like to thank my dog my
fish my Lobster my dodo bird and Toucan
Sam over on my channel I have a bunch of
videos that are Theory based analysis
based and whatever else your heart
desires including a few things things
that any of you who are theorists might
want to check out and I like to interact
with all of you so don't be shy to
communicate again thank you so much to
the entire team behind the film Theory
videos this has been super fun and
absolutely amazing and lastly as we wrap
things up this is one final reminder of
our film Theory holiday merch the
awesome film Theory Academy hoodie to
keep you nice and cozy this winter the
matching screen fiend t-shirt this
mysterious little analog horror VHS
plushie that can terrify you when you
snuggle up it also may have secrets of
its own to unlock just make sure you get
your orders in either today or tomorrow
to ensure delivery Before Christmas
again all of that is down on the merch
shelf or in the description and as
always I'll see you next week